[Musique]
encore mieux j'en dirai plus clair la
corrida est indéfendable ont la vie
c'est à une passion c'est presque une
religion pour ceux qui la pratiquent
mais c'est quelque chose qui fait partie
de la culture de certains venus on envie
que tu as aussi dans peut-être on va pas
monter corrida inouva pourquoi la
question mais ça fait partie de nos
traditions régionales genou moi je suis
mis moi je suis né là j'ai eu une
émotion quand elle était menée ce
spectacle j'ai trouvé que les zones fait
d un combat magnifique valeureux
il peut par conséquent une plaque par
jeunes moines envie d'aller affronter au
taureau parce que c'est quelque chose ça
del toro et d'un animal que nous aimons
nous attire plus que nous respectons en
fermant on pourrait imaginer
bien sûr il faut l'interdire aux par une
chose c'est que l'alinéa 7 protège des
combats de coqs dans le nord pas de
calais dans les piles ultramarins
là on parle de la comida il faut
interdire est très très très rapidement
la corrida dans tout le sud de la france
je suis né à nîmes au slim j'ai vu une
corrida j'ai une émotion aussi le
contraire d'un monsieur cette émotion
m'a fait dire que ne fallait plus jamais
allé voir une corrida
c'était un spectacle monstrueux ce mot
tradition m'insupporte un peu parce que
c'est importé 2 d'espagne la première
corrida il ya près de 150 ans elle est
légale dans le sud de la france à des
santolines depuis 1951
non monsieur lesur dit qu'on peut pas
faire deux corridas à tourcoing normal
c'est interdit le matador est un
délinquant
sauf dans le sud où il est protégé par
un alinéa auroux disent que c'est de
l'art mais la corrida est un leurre
c'est que le viol de l'amour
nos politiques au sein de nos
gouvernants aux gens d'âge donc ils vont
ils suivre auvignon voilà est donc dans
les faits dans les territoires locaux où
la corrida
les heurts de noblesse il ya ma foi ils
sont adoptés rentable tous les mails une
association s'appelle l'union des maires
le touring de france elle son pouce en
faveur de la corrida et puis donc des
hommes politiques au niveau national
comme ils savent qu'en france n'a pas la
majorité sur la corrida
ils oublient d'en parler voilà un michel
de carolis qui vient récemment d'être
élu maire d'arles les la défense de la
tauromachie d'afrique des pieds et des
mains pour que la corrida et lieu
dimanche dernier dans sa commune voilà
mais non dans le sens de la population
et qu'est ce qu'elle veut la population
je voudrais finir par la corniche la
paix qu'on laisse aller voir les
taureaux à ce que les taureaux et ce
qu'ils ne paraîtront la pêche à la
chasse ou pardonnez moi vous vous
promenez à la campagne quoi voilà la
corrida ou l'abolition ou pour qu on
n'appartient pas à un parti politique
c'est ni à droite ni à gauche ni au
milieu là c'est le dernier sondage ifop
avait craint commandé il ya reçu il ya
trois ou quatre jours je vous fais grâce
des offres page là monsieur veut dire
que pour les autobus à dire le sud de la
france les 65 % des gens sont opposés à
la corrida
le centre 5% je n'invente pas assez les
formes monsieur voilà et 60% sont
opposés à l'entrée des enfants de moins
de saison dans une arène assez la zone
taurine parle pas de la france entière
j'ai pris le plus intéressant l'acteur
audit recul dans le sud dans les zones
taurine les majoritairement pour la
corrida c'est faux alors pourquoi les
politiques ne veulent pas débattre là
dessus je vous avoue que je n'insisterai
qui n'a rien j'ai mon opinion perso j'en
pleure ça fait des voix par exemple
monsieur et or m je pense que sa famille
aussi et or un an que dans ma famille on
va viser tout chasseur
et ça fait des voix est ce qu'il ya des
wagons et derrière je n'en sais
strictement rien la majorité des
français même à l'échelon national gelé
l'association est contre ça entre ça je
ne sais pas peut-être qu'un jour on aura
la réponse je ne sais pas à mon sens
monsieur nos rétines et à un ministre
c'est un intellectuel
voilà il ya beaucoup d'ingrédients iem
la tauromachie
parce qu'ils ont connu de l'intérieur et
ils signent pas de celle des écrivains
des artistes etc du point de vue
intellectuel ou défendre la tauromachie
et il a défendu avant d'être ministre
banny prononcer des discours en public
en faveur de la commune a donc ça va
tout à fait aléatoire pour moi il n'a
rien à voir on va sur moretti ce n'est
pas le ministre qui va dans un fil à
rennes
l'un dernière une à lui 2 il a sans
arrêt là tout le temps les mêmes anime
les lézards anonyme
il ya même un endroit vip si vous être
bien vu il faut accepter d'aller
assister à une corrida d'un seul car
hélas rien dire et voilà mais par contre
monsieur moretti lui sont attribués il
défend la corrida je pense que vu sa
position actuelle manque de respect